hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video Rebecca on foreigner again and at
the end of the 400 EV stream they showed
a little bit of a teaser for the season
10 hero so we're gonna be talking about
that as always like to be if you do
enjoy subscribe if you're new I covered
the informational site a foreigner that
being the balance changes the hero
updates the patch notes those leaks so
if you want to be kept up today with
everything happening within the world of
400f we stay subscribe to the channel
and with that my Twitter and discord
will be in the description if you guys
want to join that and let's get started
so this was a pretty short stream there
really wasn't any info in between then
they did talk about matchmaking how they
of course are gonna reset the MMR at the
end of the season and then try to make
it better of course they always
mentioned things about making
matchmaking better personally to me I
don't really see how it does work
because I've never really noticed the
difference but maybe they just haven't
fixed it or maybe it takes a lot of time
I'm not I'm not a tech guy so I wouldn't
know they also went over some cool
tournaments that was pretty nice to see
but at the very end they showed this
teaser for the new hero of season 10 we
don't have a name we don't have a name
of the weapon we have literally nothing
but this image so far just going off
first impression he's definitely going
to be a bigger character bait just based
off of how thick the arm on him is he
has some dolls on his waist tied
together probably by some rope and an
image of the new axe that we that we've
seen for a few months with the teasers
of the year three roadmap and all that
stuff but this one definitely looks a
little bit different after doing a
little research I believe the weapon is
called mas Akari or another word is oh
no but this could be completely wrong
I'm not very ver I'm not well versed
within the Japanese folklore and
anything like that so I could totally be
wrong with this but this weapon was
mostly used by king taro who is I
apparently a small chubby child in the
Japanese folklore now this obviously is
not going to mean that the character is
going to be a child that wouldn't make
any sense but maybe this is him grown up
maybe that could be the name of the new
hero or something like that but either
way this axe this outfit looking real
nice but going off that the overall
weapon actually has some incredible
detail lots of engravings and curves
throughout the blade as well as the
staff towards the bottom has some really
nice Catchings within the wood staff you
could tell by the wear and tear of the
doll heads that this man has definitely
been through some [ __ ] and of course the
thirst skulls around him on the corner
of the picture so yeah he's definitely
been through some [ __ ] he kind of
reminds me of Shu goki just based off
the guns that he's wearing in this
and it seemed like his arm is gonna be
exposed than the default armor so we
might be able to see something like he
might be wearing a tank top or something
like that but he Amell but he might also
be trying to flex a little bit on his
really big buff muscles which proves
more proves more of my point that he is
going to be a bigger character probably
going to be a heavy for this season
that's all I really have for this
character there really isn't much to go
off of seeing as this is just an image
as opposed to marching fire when we had
a teaser like this it was maybe a
three-second clip which that was
actually a video this is a little bit
different again let me know your
comments down below with this next week
as you can tell by the image is going to
be a reveal stream April 25th I will be
sure to cover that I don't got anything
going on that day of course so I'm
definitely going to be covering that as
usual so definitely stay I look out on
the channel they're probably gonna be
showing some gameplay some execution
some really cool stuff about the
character and we'll actually get a first
look at him now we haven't actually
gotten a trailer for this character yet
last season we did give one for Season 9
for more dagur and that was actually
around this time this week
so we're either going to be getting a
trailer sometime this weekend or next
week leading up to the reveal or maybe
we won't get a trailer at all I really
do hope we get a trailer because I'd
love to see what this character looks
like you know the dialogue the lore I
think that'd be really sick to look at
but yeah as always with these types of
videos I'm not a one-man army I have you
guys to help me with that so of course
leave the comments down below of what
you guys think about any of this image
if you know some more lore or any type
of Japanese story that I don't cuz I'm
like I said I'm not very well versed so
you can maybe tell me what the weapon is
who the character might be some names
and then I can maybe provide some
pictures and stuff like that I'd love to
know in the comments down below
but with that like the V if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new I cover the
informational side of foreigner that
being the balance changes the hero
updates the patents and the leaks so be
kept up to date with everything
happening within the world of foreigner
definitely stay subscribe to the channel
as I said in the beginning my Twitter
and discord are down in the description
below if you want to check those and
join those that'd be highly appreciated
and with that take care guys my two most
as new videos will be popping up on
screen and peace out enjoy the new
executions that also just dropped
[Music]
you
[Music]